imagine this for a moment climbing to
the top of a peak more than five miles
high in elevation Mountaineers call the
Death Zone the air has about one-third
of the oxygen it does at sea level and
the human body body literally starts to
shut down
now think about skiing all the way down
after you've done that it may sound
impossible but only on CBS this morning
Jan Crawford hit the slopes with a
couple who just got into the record
books by doing exactly that
Jan joins us from Washington Jan good
morning
well good morning John you know this is
really a story about perseverance and
believing that you can survive Hillary
Nelson a Jim Morrison are two of the
world's most elite skiers they've both
overcome these incredible challenges
physical and emotional to reach the
pinnacle of their sport
now they invited us to their home in
Telluride Colorado and then they had
another challenge getting me to the top
of one of America's most scenic ski
resorts so we could see how they did it
this is one of the reasons I love being
in the mountains of this beautiful the
peaks of the San Juan Mountains are some
of America's highest here at 12,000 feet
here we go see where you train yeah
adventurers Hillary Nelson and Jim
Morrison are going to show us where they
trained for the impossible take care of
me yeah for a novice skier like me even
this flat bid at the top of Telluride
ski resort was daunting take a deep
breath but it was the only way to see
this view of where the couple pursued a
dream that's another cool R that shoots
down through that rock face and we see
that quite a baby through that
yes it's called side country skiing
their focus was half a world away
soaring five miles in the sky that
little peak in the back is the fourth
highest mountain in the world right next
to Everest there that so-called little
peak was a twenty-eight thousand foot
mountain in the Himalayas called lo se
and last fall after three years of
preparation
they not only climbed up it this is hard
they did something no one had ever done
before
top of the world they skied down it
7,000 feet down its face drops in
uncharted unimaginable conditions no
room for error the smallest thing that
goes wrong with your plan can mean a big
difference between your eventual success
or failure or life and death yeah you
have to wonder why what drives people
like Nelson and Morrison to push their
limits
Nelson grew up playing sports before
skiing became her passion I think
there's something really powerful about
being persistent at some things and I
think it's really important to live
outside of this box we all create around
ourselves and tell us what you can and
can't do now a mother of two boys she
also sees her career as a lesson for
life more than anything they understand
the lesson is that it's really hard to
take that first step just try try yeah
just try and you might not be able to do
it but at least you tried and so then
you know where how far you can push
yourself a little bit further the next
time eyes hurt lungs hurt more pushing
their way up loads they came with its
share of suffering but for Morrison the
physical pain on the mountain was
nothing compared to the emotional trauma
he went through seven years ago a trauma
that's driven him to scale the world's
highest peaks I lost my wife and
children in a plane crash in 2011 and my
world was ended in an instant did you
ever think you just can't go on yes I
found a way to get out in the mountains
and do something that I loved and do
something that I'm passionate about and
do something physically active
helped me process my loss four years
after the tragedy while climbing in
Nepal Morrison met Nelson who had gone
through a painful divorce six months
later they began a romantic relationship
give anything in the world to not have
had him go through what you've gone
through but not having that ability to
take those things away has made us who
we are
Morrison's path to healing came full
circle last spring while he was on a
peak next to load say Mount Everest I
spent about 45 minutes climbing by
myself in this place that I was totally
connected to my kids and I felt like I
was closer to them and I'd been in years
did you talk to them I talked to them a
little bit I talked to myself I get gold
and laughed and I was totally alone at
28,000 feet like you're that close to
heaven it was like I was on the edge of
heaven a few months later Morrison was
back on the roof of the world onload say
this time his companion was the woman
who was defining the next chapters of
his life we had a lot of life to live
before we found each other and found our
connection and a lot of good things
happen and a lot of bad things happen
for both of us and those are things we
share now and understand each other are
probably better climbing partners and
skiing partners because of it I think
we've been through enough experiences
that we really appreciate it's just
being in the moment and those moments
now shared together whether unloads say
or here in the rocky mountain backyard
are pretty spectacular now Hillary and
Jim say there have been times on
expeditions when they look at each other
and ask can we just be climbing partners
and not boyfriend and girlfriend but
more often they say it's their deep
personal bond that really came from that
intense tragedy and pain that makes them
stronger and so good at what they do
bianna o Jan I'm just so glad they found
each other and you know when we're
teasing this story you wonder why
someone would do
that and when he explained that it
brings him closer to his children it all
makes sense well I love what she said I
think there's something really powerful
about being persistent at something and
anybody who's good at something knows
you have to be incredibly persistent Jam
thank you so much a story yeah